make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so in the last video we did on MCU
villains which again is basically a
series designed to kind of ask the
question can a villain a particular type
of villain or someone who could be made
into a villain fit in the MCU we focused
on Doctor Doom right which I love Doctor
Doom he's one of my favorite characters
and I figured kind of a great way to
start the series in this one I want to
focus on Galactus now when it comes to
Galactus in the MCU one of the questions
that people are kind of asking right now
is if they come in and they say that
like you know like he debuts in the
Fantastic Four you know that movie or
whatever it is and they say well you
know Galactus has been here the entire
time one of the questions people would
ask is well then why didn't he do
anything during infinity war and
Avengers in game if Galactus were in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe during the
events of infinity war in Avengers in
game um he wouldn't care but it wouldn't
matter to him that Thanos had wiped out
half the life of the universe and the
reason why is because Galactus consumes
life-sustaining planets right like he
consumes worlds he doesn't really care
about the people on them when it comes
to it when it comes to Marvel Comics
there's a kind of pecking order right I
mean and it's not necessarily based on
power it's more based on like the world
you have and your significance
especially when it's in relation to
Galactus right in terms of the people
Galactus cares enough to talk to when it
comes to this pecking order if someone
for example like Peter quill we're just
kind of floating around and flying on
the the universe and what-have-you and
came across a world where Galactus was
essentially like destroying it in
pursuit of you know absorbing all of his
energies and he tried to stop him and
said hey Galactus you can't do this
Galactus was just ignored as far as he's
conservative quills just to fly this not
really worthy of his acknowledgment but
someone like Reed Richards is and
there's a couple different reasons why
the first is because in the original
Galactus trilogy when he first showed up
on earth and met the Fantastic Four
initially he have plans to consume it
and for the most part was just ignoring
everybody on it and then Reed Richards
showed up with the ultimate nullifier
which was a device that basically if you
pointed at somebody or something you can
essentially wipe them from existence um
he showed up with a nullifier in tow a
Galactus if you don't leave I'm gonna
shoot you with this that's like a lot
just left
no altum Utley he ended up banishing
Silver Surfer to earth and confined him
there but but because of the fact that
earth had people who are going to stand
up to Galactus
that kind of raised an eyebrow right so
while he didn't necessarily acknowledge
Reid as being like a character worth you
know seeing kind of eye to eye to or
worthy of respect and subsequent stories
that began to change and it really all
kind of came together there during the
story of the trial of Reed Richards so
this story unfolded by having a scenario
where I believe Galactus was dying and
Reed Richards chose to save him or
something along those lines worries it
was something like Reed Richards
basically acted and preserved the life
of Galactus and so as a result a kind of
coming together of the various empires
throughout Marvel took place so you had
to create the scrolls the Shiar the dune
the Medora you had like a whole bunch of
these different races that kind of came
together and they basically put Reed
Richards on trial and the argument was
because of the fact that he allowed
Galactus to live whether by his action
or inaction then what it meant was a
Galactus would continue going around the
universe consuming worlds and Reed was
essentially he was complicit in an
accomplice to the deaths of future
billions trillions and untold numbers
because he allowed Galactus to continue
on and so what happened is you ended up
having eternity who stepped in now if
those guys who were not familiar with
eternity eternity is basically what
would happen if the universe could get
up and walk around right like the
universe of given form is basically what
he turned he is he what reasons the
space that makes up the universe
infinity represents the time that passes
from the origin of the universe until
its end
so they're basically like brother and
sister right time and space and so
because of that um eternity stepped in
and said Galactus is a necessity
he's a universal constant the purpose
Galactus serves is to travel from one
world to the next consuming its energies
that can sustain life and while it does
destroy the universe does destroy the
world in the process what it also does
is it keeps the celestial population in
check because the Celestials basically
procreate by planting their seeds in
world that can support life and then
though much like I guess like a fetus in
the womb the the celestial as an egg
begins to essentially feed on the energy
that makes up that world and then once
it grows to maturity and it's ready to
be born so to speak it explodes out from
the core of the world and destroys the
world everybody on in the process
but if Galactus didn't exist in Galactus
did not travel around the cosmos
consuming life-sustaining worlds then
the celestial population would overrun
it would do they would overrun the
entire universe there would be a huge
population and the universe will be out
of balance and then at that point the
living Tribune will probably stepped in
and either wipe it all away or like
create Galactus or something along those
lines but whatever the case Galactus is
a necessity he has to be there and the
role he serves is a kind of checks and
balance in the universe the other half
of that is is the kind of mirror effect
that Galactus has right so Galactus is a
being of pure energy is really what he
is right I mean to kind of get into the
origin of his character for a second so
we can look at the MCU as it exists
right now
and we can say that like everything
we've seen in the last ten years right
like since the release of Iron Man 1
running all the way up to the eventual
Avengers in game that's the MCU version
- right let me it's the the second
version of the MCU before that is MCU
version 1 we don't know what that
universe looked like but we can and we
can go ahead and grab the comic book
version of Galactus and throw it into
the MCU and say that in that Marvel
Cinematic Universe version 1 that there
was a space explorer named Galan and he
was you know traveling around the cosmos
because the universe was coming to an
end and he couldn't figure out why and
he basically failed to find out he never
really discovered what the cause of the
universe's destruction was instead what
ended up happening is that in the
universe's final moments when it was
about to end it was literally crushing
in on itself in this this big crunch
that the the version of eternity from
the first universe merged with Galactus
and then I guess merged with Galan and
then he kind of went to this sort of
this cocoon more or less and so that
when the universe was born into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe version 2 the
one that you've been watching for the
last 10 years Galactus was born along
with it and Galactus having this cocoon
for like billions and billions of years
right like for countless years you know
for billions and millions of years but
what he was doing was basically
understanding his energy figuring out
how his power worked and then sort of
designing a suit that would essentially
regulate all those energies so that once
he emerged he would go through and to
start consuming all these
life-sustaining worlds because of the
fact that Galactus is a being of pure
energy
he's a mirror to whoever sees him right
so with Galactus shows up on earth he
look like an Earthling if the light just
shows up on the Kree homeworld he'll
look like a Kree
and if Galactus shows up on the scroll
homeworld he'll look like a scroll
that's one of the things that came out
of the trial of Reed Richards you know I
kind of tie back around to the first
question right you know why didn't
why did inviting Galactus actor and
infinity war and Avengers in-game people
will look to the idea of Infinity
Gauntlet and they will say well he acted
during that story right like during the
events of Infinity Gauntlet in the
comics Galactus stepped in and along
with the other cosmic entities tried to
defeat Thanos but the motivation is
between Thanos and the comics and Thanos
and the movie are starkly different
right in the comics all he does he's
he's a nihilist right he believes life
is meaningless and he wants to appease
mistress death is Clegane or affection
by inflicting as much death and
destruction as you possibly can when he
got the Infinity Gauntlet the
perspective of Adam warlock was well he
wiped out half the life in the universe
he's going to try to destroy everything
later on we have to stop him while we
can and the movies is totally different
it's not really about appeasing mistress
death he's not really a nihilist he
doesn't believe that life is meaningless
he just believes that overpopulation is
basically taking away from everything
now having said that um in terms of
actually establishing him and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe this is where things
get difficult because Galactus is not
really a traditional straight-up villain
his motivations aren't rooted and like
just being a dick or like just
intentionally inflicting harm on others
he's not self-serving
right it's not like an acquisition of
wealth is what drives Galactus to do the
things he does or like an acquisition of
power or something along those lines he
does what he does because it's a
necessity and so it's interesting
because to to make the lactis of villain
would be tantamount to making like the
son of they're not even the son really
like a black hole a villain right like
black hole this this hole in in space
and time is a collapsed dead star with a
singularity at the center and everything
to fly everything that comes near you
know past the event horizon gets sucked
in to basically be broken down on the
atomic level never to be seen or heard
from again the only way to really make
that work would be to introduce as a
character this in there and you don't
really depict him as a villain he
doesn't really have villainous motives
he's more of a villain by circumstance
like hit by it by the virtue of his
existence he inflicts death and
destruction and so because of that like
they have to basically stop him in order
to like save a world right like it's
done in such a way to where it's like
he's just kind of a thing that exists
and it's not really right or wrong it
just is it
the circumstances that make him up here
make him appear to be a villain that's
really the only way you could throw him
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
anything beyond that and and it gets a
little kind of crazy and a little a
little hokey but you could definitely
put him in there the question the
question that I have is what do you do
after that right like if you introduce
Galactus and then you basically say he's
this being that's there he's not really
good he's not really evil he just kind
of exists and then like he consumes
worlds then then you would have to kind
of craft circumstances that would lead
to Galactus his involvement and would
see him either fighting on behalf of
people or fighting against them or
something along those lines which we've
seen happen in the comics right I mean
there's a zillion different
circumstances when Infinity Gauntlet
infinity war things like that but it's
usually Galactus acting and preservation
of himself and the universe right like
if a being is powerful enough to destroy
the universe they're powerful enough to
destroy blackness so Galactus by virtue
of being destroyed if the universe were
destroyed ends up acting because you
know it's really I guess some measure of
preservation and his own self-interest
but whatever the case is it's the
circumstances that that that really
involved Galactus more than like the
nature of Galactus himself so I don't
know I mean it's it's it's kind of
difficult to do but it's kind of
difficult to take a being that's not
inherently evil and then put him in a
movie and make him appear inherently
evil right I mean you know and almost
kind of like have the audience walk away
believing that guy is inherently bad um
I think people would be more interested
in just seeing like the force of
Galactus right seeing like a lot just
brought in being done properly instead
of just a clown's an octopus cloud and
then and then in turn like showing like
here's this being with an insane amount
of power here's a funny thing and in
infinity war and an Avengers in game the
way the Infinity Gauntlet was used by
Thanos never really maximized his full
potential outside of snapping his
fingers and blinking out hath aligned
the universe front like that was a big
moment but it kind of makes sense
because if he got the gauntlet and the
big moment at the end of infinity which
we all knew was going to be him snapping
out half the life of the universe you
wouldn't want to have him do something
that would make that look small by
comparison right I mean you you wouldn't
necessarily want to have a scenario
where like the analyst is fighting with
the Infinity Gauntlet against you know
some heroes or something like that and
then like turns the earth into a giant
popcorn ball like you you wouldn't want
to do something like that because it
would take away from the significance of
him wiping out half the life in the
universe and so with that in mind like
like having to like just show up in the
MCU I wouldn't be surprised at the kind
of power he displays actually seems like
it exceeds the power of what we saw with
the Infinity Gauntlet
but that was only because of the fact
that the Infinity Gauntlet as it was
used by Thanos was not really used to
its full potential
I mean it's if it was you would have
seen a far more grandiose display of
power than what you saw in both movies
um but I imagine you know just by just
by virtue of perspective you know you
would see you know boga like us uses
power whatever it is you know
resurrection body from the dead or like
create a whole world or something along
those lines anyway I feel like I've
rambled on long enough so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explained make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]